[Music]
what's up alex
not much how you been man excellent
what's up how can we help
uh well i'm 17 and here in about two
weeks i turn 18 and i gained access to a
trust run from some lawsuits when i was
a kid for some medical issues okay and
it's quite a bit of money and i was just
calling to see like
uh what what do i go
like what do i do about that like it's
how much money it's more money than i've
ever been accustomed to how much
3.5 million 3.5 million okay are you
are your parents
in the room with you
uh no they're not i'm i asked that the
wrong way are your parents in your life
yeah yeah okay are they gonna be helping
you with this
yeah
i'm just gonna okay
when it comes to this amount of money at
your age
it would do you uh a solid to have a
long pause before we do anything with
this money and there's going to be a lot
of people who are going to want a piece
of this who are going to be happy to
help you manage this money alex people
are gonna come out of the woods they're
gonna come off your roof they're gonna
come out everywhere
now have you had a job before
i've always had summer jobs but i'm an
athlete all year round so it's just like
a summer gig
okay
well there's only three things you can
do with money you can give it you can
save it and you can spend it and at your
age i would focus on the first two
before the spending part because this
can easily become like richie rich style
you know you're like buying the mansion
you got the fancy car
and at 17 years old you still have like
another i don't know 80 something years
to live
and so if you manage this well you won't
have to worry about money ever again
or you could go full prodigal son and it
could be gone tomorrow
yeah
is it okay for me to like go out and
like purchase the house at like 19 next
year i would not like is that okay
you need a house not a matter of okay
yeah why would you do that
i mean i don't know it's just like it
seems like a smart thing to do i live 4
000 miles away via one two
three
four cities away from where i was at 19.
the idea that you would buy a house at
night i just don't know why you would do
that yeah you've got the money but i
don't know why you're gonna go to
college you're gonna go to school
yeah
yeah was there money saved up for that
outside of the settlement
uh no it that is part of like that's
going towards my college okay
so i would sit down with your parents
and say what's the game plan with this
money
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna go
to college debt free
go buy a car and don't buy a tesla buy a
used truck and get yourself to and from
school right and it's listen to me alex
i'm asking you to do something that most
people on planet earth would not do
and that is to look at 3.5 million
dollars to buy 20 000 car
okay
most people would not have the
discipline to do that and you're taught
you're you're you're acting now
for 35 year old alex and your two or
three kids that you don't even know yet
you haven't even named them yet yeah
okay
so
i'd put the rest with your smartmaster
pro and they're gonna not put their
hands in all your money they're not
gonna spend all their time trying to
figure out how they can bilk you out of
this thing and you're gonna let it grow
and grow and grow do you have any debt
alex
oh no none okay i wanna keep it that way
for the rest of your life and that's
gonna help you make the most of this
money i want you to have an emergency
fund once you have a picture of what
your life looks like maybe beyond
college
of three to six months and i want you to
be investing 15 of your income from
whatever job you have so let's pretend
this money even isn't there then when it
comes time to buy a reasonable car like
john's talking about we do that with
cash when it comes time to buy a
reasonable house maybe once you're
married
maybe we do that
beyond that i want you to have a
assemble a team
and you can do that at
ramseysolutions.com we've got people in
the tax industry in the real estate
industry
in the investing industry you've got to
start assembling your team of people who
care about alex who want alex to win
who can help you do things the smart way
who have your interest at heart and so
that's what your best move right now is
make a game plan with your parents and
assemble that team of people who can
help you manage this well and be a good
steward of what was given to you hey
alex um this is a hard question i'm
going to ask you are your parents
trustworthy
uh my mother yeah okay
um
if this money has a specific legal
designations this money is for you this
is your money um
i can see a scenario and i'm not saying
this is your parents your dad or your
mom a scenario where
people want this your parents want this
money to pay off their house pay off
their debts to pay off their things so
if you find yourself in a situation
where you are feeling uncomfortable
that other people are using you as a
lottery ticket it might be a cousin
there'll be a so they're going to be
several cousins that come out of the
woods on this one
um yeah it's best to say i'm going to
not continue this conversation right now
and go get with a smartbuster pro go get
with a legal professional this is enough
money that i might even reach out and
get an attorney that's gonna help me
walk through this and at the end of the
day protect me
not from myself even but protect me from
other folks around um
man
the fact that you're 17 years old and
you thought to make the phone call that
you're thinking i want to do this right
tells me that you're way way ahead of
the game man
as george said you got 80-something
years to go
so slow play this you're in no hurry
you've got your college taken care of
and that's the next
what three four five years of your life
then let's let's invest in alex right
now because he still has to live a life
he's going to work a job you're not just
going to live on an island somewhere but
if you invest i did some math for you
invest 3 million of this
over 30 years
you're going to have upwards of 50 to 60
million dollars sitting there imagine
what you could do for your community the
ways you could give
man
yeah that's inspiring exactly man the
the yeah because you were a good steward
of this and didn't blow it to look showy
on instagram and i don't feel that from
alex at all no man but man that's a lot
of weight to put on a 17 year old yeah
so call us back if you need help along
the way man we're here for you